in a year of climate disasters world
leaders have fallen well short of the
science time is fast running out to keep
global warming below 1.5 degrees
yet the cop 27 Summit failed to agree
stronger cuts to carbon emissions and
proposals to phase out all fossil fuels
were blocked
but let's be clear our planet is still
in the emergency room
we need to drastically reduce emissions
now and this is an issue this cop did
not address
the planet is heading for a temperature
rise of 2.7 degrees making irreversible
tipping points like the collapse of the
Greenland ice sheet more likely for
climate scientists there is deep
frustration what they don't understand
is how urgent this is the change or an
impacts if we are warming the globe on
average and you know there are many
parts of the world which will not be on
average
to one and a half or two is a vastly
different change
to people to ecosystems to our crops to
our water supplies
the cost of not doing something now will
result in hugely larger costs later
there is the consolation though of a
breakthrough on a fund for loss and
damage to poor countries that have done
little to cause the climate crisis but
are suffering most from the impacts
so how might a loss and damage fund work
well rich countries like the UK EU
United States and others would put money
in the tin and it would pay out to
poorer countries like Pakistan or Island
States like the Maldives who could be
submerged by rising sea levels but
arguments remain over countries still
officially classed as developing despite
having comparative wealth like China
currently the world's biggest greenhouse
gas polluter and the Gulf States like
Saudi Arabia that are major sources of
fossil fuels whether they put money in
won't be decided until next year's
climate conference it was very important
that this fund was established you know
as I say developing countries have been
calling for this for 30 years there has
been these uh talks are you know
beleagued by a lack of trust across the
board not least because developed
countries have promised Finance again
and again and again and they haven't
delivered on that Finance the next
climate conference will be in the United
Arab Emirates one of the world's biggest
producers of oil and gas Europe and the
UK will once again push hard to keep 1.5
degrees alive but just as they did in
Egypt they are likely to face a strong
headwind from the fossil fuel Lobby
Thomas More Sky News